We will now continue and
derive some additional
properties of probability laws
which are, again, consequences
of the axioms that we
have introduced.
The first property
is the following.
If we have two sets
and one set is
smaller than the other--
so we have a picture
as follows.
We have our sample space.
And we have a certain set, A.
And then we have a certain set,
B, which is even bigger.
So the set B is the
bigger blue set.
So if B is a set which is
larger than A, then,
naturally, the probability that
the outcome falls inside
B should be at least as big as
the probability that the
outcome falls inside A.
How do we prove this formally?
The set B can be expressed
as a union of two pieces.
One piece is the set A itself.
The second piece is whatever
elements of B there are, that
do not belong in A. What
are these elements?
They are elements that belong
to B. And they do not belong
to A, which means that they
belong to the complement of A.
So we have expressed the set B
as the union of two pieces.
Now this piece is A. This piece
here is outside A. So
these two pieces are disjoint.
And so we can apply the
additivity axiom, and write
that the probability of B is
equal to the probability of A
plus the probability
of the other set.
And since probabilities are
non-negative, this expression
here is at least as large as the
probability of A. And this
concludes the proof of
the property that
we wanted to show.
Indeed, the probability of A is
less than or equal to the
probability of B.
The next property we will
show is the following.
It allows us to write the
probability of the union of
two sets for the case now, where
the two sets are not
necessarily disjoint.
So the picture is as follows.
We have our two sets, A
and B. These sets are
not necessarily disjoint.
And we want to say something
about the probability of the
union of A and B.
Now the union of A and B
consists of three pieces.
One piece is this one here.
And that piece consists of those
elements of A that do
not belong to B. So they
belong to B complement.
This set has a certain
probability, let's call it
little a and indicate
it on this diagram.
So a is the probability
of this piece.
Another piece is this one
here, which is the
intersection of A and B. It has
a certain probability that
we denote by little b.
This is the probability
of A intersection B.
And finally, there's another
piece, which is out here.
And that piece has a certain
probability c.
It is the probability
of that set.
And what is that set?
That set is the following.
It's that part of B that
consists of elements that do
not belong in A. So it's
B intersection with the
complement of A.
Now let's express the two sides
of this equality here in
terms of little a, little b, and
little c, and see whether
we get the same thing.
So the probability of A union B.
A union B consists of these
three pieces that have
probabilities little a, little
b, and little c, respectively.
And by the additivity axiom, the
probability of the union
of A and B is the sum
of the probabilities
of these three pieces.
Let's look now at the right hand
side of that equation and
see whether we get
the same thing.
The probability of A plus the
probability of B, minus the
probability of A intersection
B is equal to the following.
A consists of two pieces that
have probabilities little a
and little b.
The set B consists of two pieces
that have probabilities
little b and little c.
And then we subtract the
probability of the
intersection, which is b.
And we notice that we can
cancel here one b
with another b.
And what we are left with
is a plus b plus c.
So this checks.
And indeed we have this
equality here.
We have verified that
it is true.
One particular consequence of
the equality that we derived
is the following.
Since this term here is always
non-negative, this means that
the probability of A union B is
always less than or equal
to the probability of A plus
the probability of B. This
inequality here is quite useful
whenever we want to
argue that a certain
probability is
smaller than something.
And it has a name.
It's called the union bound.
We finally consider one last
consequence of our axioms.
And namely, we are going to
derive an expression, a way of
calculating the probability of
the union of three sets, not
necessarily disjoint.
So we have our sample space.
And within the sample space
there are three sets-- set A,
set B, and set C.
We are going to use a set
theoretic relation.
We are going to express the
union of these three sets as
the union of three
disjoint pieces.
What are these disjoint
pieces?
One piece is the set A itself.
The second piece is going to
be that part of B which is
outside A. So this is the
intersection of B with the
complement of A.
The third piece is going to be
whatever is left in order to
form the union of
the three sets.
What is left is that part of C
that does not belong to A and
that does not belong to B. So
that part is C intersection
with A complement and
B complement.
Now this set here, of course,
is the same as that set
because intersection of two sets
is the same no matter in
which order we take
the two sets.
And similarly, the set that we
have here is the same one that
appears in that expression.
Now we notice that these three
pieces, the red, the blue, and
the green, are disjoint
from each other.
So by the additivity axiom, the
probability of this union
here is going to be the sum
of the probabilities
of the three pieces.
And that's exactly
the expression
the we have up here.